from the franchisors animated beginnings
through 2018 s prequel installments and
soft reboot bumblebee get ready to
relive all the highs and lows of one of
Hollywood's most successful film series
let's see how other theatrically
released Transformers movies stack up
against each other transformers the last
night is a troubling movie sure there
are scattered flashes of brilliance like
the seaman Megatron negotiates the
release of his crewmates which does a
great job of showing the unique
personalities of the characters it also
has a cohesive tone that cleverly leans
on the humorous absurdity of
transforming robots interacting with
humans and features some really striking
dynamic camera shots that make every
moment visually engaging however the
film's good scenes are vastly
outnumbered by bad ones thanks to its
bizarre storyline which in tangles the
history of the Transformers with the
knights of the round table the central
cog of the plot - doesn't make a lick of
sense and retroactively Lee and does
things we've seen in the previous four
movies showing the writers couldn't care
less about the series story up to this
point and those aren't the only quality
control issues in the film there are
actual shots are made into the final cut
that have cameramen in them the aspect
ratio constantly changes because no one
bothered to consider that a constantly
changing border might be distracting to
viewers some central characters are
completely useless and the major plot
points are consistently underdeveloped
and lazily executed like a bumblebees
and optimises climactic faceoff in
shorts most of the last night represents
a sloppily produced missed opportunity
transformers age of extinction human
characters or lack compelling motivation
and sub personalities that range from
infuriatingly annoying too painfully
cringe-worthy and the insufferable
humans get the lion's share of screen
time because besides optimus & bumblebee
no transformer gets her real spotlights
take the Dinobots for example this movie
promoted the heck out of them and yet
they're only in the final 30 minutes of
the film and even then only in a few big
shots
the plot is another problem since it
enters much of the story that the
previous three Transformers movies
established it's not done in a crafty
way either the movie just presents its
retroactive changes to the series
continuity
and pretends no one will notice this
movie really puts the stink in
extinction Transformers Revenge of the
Fallen is a tricky one although critics
absolutely blasted it fans remain
divided on one hand has he allure of
Megan Fox's Mikaela Bane's and goofball
charm of Shia LaBeouf Sam Witwicky it
also features a lot of top-tier CGI
action and epic fights such as a forest
battle when Optimus Prime dies defending
against multiple Decepticons Plus as is
guaranteed with any Michael Bay film the
cinematography is a stylish and
stereotypically Hollywood as it gets for
fans of pretty actors likable enough
characters gorgeous cinematography and
mind-numbing ly bombastic action there's
a lot to love and revenge of the Fallen
however this movie is also loaded with a
lot of not-so-great elements the plot
contradicts itself constantly some of
the characters both human and robots are
pretty obnoxious there's a lot of crude
and the necessary humor and the tone
oscillates between serious action drama
and a juvenile comedy to clumsily for
anything to be taken seriously or
humorously blame the farting airplane
robot
with that in mind if you want some
incredible CGI action featuring
transforming robots both of the farting
and non farting variety revenge of the
Fallen can still be a fun time though it
fails to hold up by today's standards
for animated sci-fi flicks when observed
as a relic of 1986 and an ode to the
Transformers toys Transformers the movie
does a solid job beyond its fan pleasing
ultra expansive cast of transforming
robots it has other merits such as its
plot this movie story goes to some very
Game of Thrones like places in the way
that's wholly befitting of the
Transformers perpetual Civil War though
some might find it to be a bit dark a
lot of fans really love that this is the
one Transformers movie that dared to
take risks with its plot beats putting
beloved transformers lives on the line
to keep stakes high and maintain the
realism of war for all these pros
there's no getting around the fact that
the movie has issues its animation
quality is often weak the soundtrack is
infused have too much cheesy rug for its
own good and the plot fails to
articulate certain points in smart
digestible ways still the movie is a
solid 86 transformers time capsule it's
got a great voice cast core robots and
explore surprisingly risky themes
overall it sports many or most of the
key ingredients that helped get the
Transformers franchise where it is today
Transformers Dark of the Moon marked the
first time the franchise really dug deep
into historical revisionism for plot
points and it remains the only time it's
panned out well the plot uses moon
landing conspiracy theories to its
advantage and weaves them into
transformers law in a way that's both
smart and compelling giving characters
from the previous two movies new
information that organically feeds into
new missions and character arcs plus the
finale is basically just one hour of
breathtaking uninterrupted robot carnage
for those who only care about seeing
Optimus flair jetpack a swing a sword
and stab robots left and right dark of
the Moon hits all of Michael Bay's usual
beats pretty stars hot cars incredible
camerawork breathtaking scope insane
action and the lots of explosions but
this movie unlike some of Bay's others
by
all of those things up with real heart
real characters and real storytelling
plus the CGI is outstanding and the
soundtrack is killer many casual movie
goers and film critics would agree that
Michael Bay's first foray into the
transformers universe remains his best
2007 s transformers as a narrative Li
type movie that keeps its action plots
and characters all firmly planted within
our reality their word also leans
heavily on the humorous nature of its
central sci-fi premise in this sense
it's almost a Marvel movie fun minimal a
melodrama loaded with quirky likable
characters are operate within a
believable yet fantastical universe and
inoffensive well relatively inoffensive
[Music]
back in 2007 transformers set a new bar
for creativity and polish in Hollywood
visual effects which remains one of the
movie's biggest merits and a key part of
why it's remembered so fondly but it's
also beloved for being the starting
point of an engaging trilogy centered
around Shia LaBeouf Optimus Prime and
the bumblebee getting into wacky
adventures together with Shia as a
relatable stand-in for every kid who's
always wanted to meet a transformer in
real life for many people bumblebee is
likely to be the most pleasing
Transformers movie today's though the
Michael Bay movies attempted to make
everything as cool as possible
bumblebee takes a step back and focuses
almost exclusively on injecting
relatable emotion into the performance
and arc of its titular robot and lead
cast spectacle as secondary in bumblebee
and though that's going to require a
substantial gear shift for fans of the
previous films to fully appreciate its
an interesting breath of fresh air for
the franchise director Travis Knight
style revolves around sensitivity and
nuance and he handles the film's social
and interpersonal dynamics with a
delicacy and care rarely seen in
Hollywood blockbusters that alone
megasis are more easily digestible film
than most of the other transformers
flicks
that's why bumblebee reigns supreme over
its competition it may not indulge in
the pure over-the-top action of the Bey
hound instalments but is definitely a
bit more innocent as well as a good deal
more human
and for a viewing audience that's
entirely human it turns out those
qualities really matter
[Music]